justement on va profiter du fait que
vous soyez là tous les deux lluis gêne
pour faire les questions interdites du
foot français
est ce que le championnat de france est
bien le plus mauvais championnat
d'europe
hier cinq nations qui pratiquent le
football de haut niveau en europe
angleterre italie espagne allemagne et
forains la france actuellement
effectivement c'est cinquième européen
c'est le cinquième européen
c'est pourquoi parce que les mecs jouent
à l'étranger parce que dans ces pays là
que j'ai n'y a quand même il ya des
facilités a quand même des avantages
qu'en france on a pas et sur ça on
obligé de lui tirer un avantage non non
non pas ça parce qu'il ya quand même
certains aménagements parce que j'ai
vécu je fais quand même le championnat
espagnol pendant quatre ans après j'ai
pu son regard de la différence avec le
championnat français c'est totalement
différent c'est que valve avantage la
balle est footballeur il paye pas les
seuls 719 par exemple déjà fondu en
espagne tu as quand même ce
ce phénomène qui les autonomies d
autonomie de région dans le mille basque
d'autonomie catalan est automatiquement
dans ces autonomies les clubs dans ces
régions les clubs sont énormément
favoriser où on leur donne les moyens
qu'il faut éventuellement pour pouvoir
recruter pour pouvoir les nommer
certains problèmes d'argent c'est un
problème d'argent il à voir qu'en france
les charges sur les clubs sont énormes
donc ils ne peuvent pas payer les
joueurs comme les clubs étrangers les
pieds ça c'est mais ça va peut-être
s'arranger il faudrait arrêter un peu
les payer un peu trop quand même
c'est parce que les champions du monde
nos meilleurs joueurs sont quand même à
l'étranger paris mais ce qui reste quand
même pas les meilleurs à ce qu'on avait
encore le championnat conçu qui
resterait d'europe à la voile a alors
deuxième question est pour vous un luis
fernandez les vraies raisons entre nous
les yeux dans les yeux les vraies
raisons de la défaite des bleus au corps
et la corée certainement que un joueur
comme zizou n'était pas à 100% à
l'équipe blessure est content on a un
garçon c'est inédit nzila non mais c'est
important
c'est comme si tu enlèves à réal de
madrid un raul loin à la jupe del piero
et on va sentir tout de suite ce que ça
fait ça vient ça fait que le groupe ne
peut pas on se repose toujours sur ce
garçon mais quand on voit le talent
qu'il a et l'apport qu'il a dans le
groupe
ça fait énormément c'est la première
raison les autres après on peut pas
toujours l'efféminé quand même
l'entraîneur il ya quand même aussi il y
en a énormément de doré il ya beaucoup
de responsables de la préparation
peut-être mais peut-être que moi je
pense que personnellement ce match
amical qui était programmé c'était
encore et premier corps et quelques
jours avant le service prive pas n'avait
peut-être pas raison de lieu de rs que
vous dites là luis fernandez c'est une
idée si ni d'alcool
non non je pense pas non je crois pas je
crois pas que les garçons soient partis
la banche et islas money d'antibes il ya
ici aussi le côté ou quand les champions
du monde théâtral est automatiquement
les sénégalais se sont quand ce ne sont
pas des mauvais jours bonjour ils jouent
tous dans notre championnat ou dans des
championnats étrangers
et c'est pour ça que c'est important
quand tu commences à une compétition
ensuite ça s'enchaîne mal
luis est ce que vous touchez du blé de
la marque de sucettes non
ah bon non pourtant vous êtes sans arrêt
je peux pas dire le peut pas dire non
pas le dire alors non mais il m'envoyait
des bons jours il a tancé les quais de
luis fernandez ne paye pas ses suspects
mais offre m
n'est-il pas temps jeunes saccomano que
thierry roland et jean michel larqué
prennent leur retraite
non je crois pas et je le dis très
sincèrement je le dis très sincèrement
hockey parce que sur le commentaire des
matchs de football
thierry est encore loin le meilleur
c'est luiz qui ronfle non mais je
remplis bah moi je m'endors et
et quant à l'arc et bat larqué il
explique bien comme un no 1 tu sais
quand il dit qu'il y paraît dans ses
commentaires à la radio et par ici mais
on n'a pas non plus enlever quand même
que thierry et jean michel ont quand
même énormément apporté au bêtisier
est ce que le football féminin un vrai
intérêt
oui oui il a un gros intérêt
d'abord c'est le sport c'est un des
sports les plus pratiqués aux états unis
alors ce qui est un peu désolant pour
nous les machos européens surtout latin
c'est de savoir que aux états unis on
considère le football comme un sport de
bronze f1 ce qui est épouvantable et
c'est vrai que ce sont les filles qui
font l'essentiel du football aux états
unis
elles sont d'ailleurs les coups francs
parce qu'on voit les mecs qui se
protègent les couilles comme en grèce
qu'elles ont les mêmes gestes protège
les seins elles ont des des soutiens
gorges c'est vrai nom mais s'est
présenté sur la chasse you un peu
spéciaux quelquefois comme elisabeth
alesi est ce que guy roux ne suis pas
trop de pub à la télé à venir ou ses
bons amis
elle adore oui et non il fait pas
beaucoup de pub un projet beaucoup c'est
sûr
à trop jeune il avait beaucoup la
question c'est trop il ramasse il
ramassera marin peur d'en perdre en
chemin
et donc s'il est comme ça pourquoi pas
hein
il dit qu'il n'est pas comme ça hein
mais il est comme il est exceptionnel il
est formé d'un formidable non la jambe
moi j'aime beaucoup est-ce que supporter
une équipe de football
roncq ont je crois que c'est terrible de
dire ça mais je crois que quand même
quelque fois s'en est ce que les jeunes
aient toutes les franges comprenez ce
que leur disait le maire je pense que
non c'est à dire qu'il est difficilement
il était lui brûle difficilement
compréhensible donc il fallait être très
très fort pour saisir les subtilités du
discours de m
c'est pas très gentil devient championne
du monde avec roger lemerre
comme aimé jacquet sans raccrocher le
maire pensant condanmé sont champions
d'europe et que ce soir-là contre
l'italie en finale il a un coup de génie
de coaching de changer deux jours et ces
deux jours amènent ce but vainqueur
c'est quand même à c'est le maire qui
fait le coaching voilà exactement et toi
tu étais premier lieu c'est une planète
chez ces gens là on a été champions
d'europe avant après avoir été
championne du monde et ça c'est
mentalement c'est français c'est comme
ça c'est si c'est ce que vous allez né
un jour l'autre après vous détruisez ou
le brûler c'est comme ça par rapport au
début il ya un respect de dés des
joueurs qui ont joué dans les années 60
ou qui sont encore et on respecte et
qu'on essaie c'est dans l'histoire c'est
dans la tradition
si c'est ça se perd ça ça n'existe par
des poudres nom et son nom
c'est comme un nom en revenant sur essai
de lundi soir et luis fernandez sur est
jeune et j'étais bien que la bombe le
match